an dem man diesen satz sagen muss es
herrscht krieg in europa russland ist in
die ukraine einmarschiert putin hat sich
nicht aushalten lassen die welt ist die
größte sorge viele sprechen von der
dunkelsten stunde europa seit dem
zweiten weltkrieg und die menschen in
der ukraine die bangen um die land und
viele auch um ihr leben und hoffen auf
hilfe aus dem westen die europäische
union setzt auf schärfere sanktionen
aber wird das reichen um die
nuklearmacht russland zu stoppen putins
krieg angriff auf die ukraine jetzt in
der phoenix runde
[Musik]
phoenix runde
mit seinem angriff auf die ukraine
bricht der russische präsident putin
abermals eklatant das völkerrecht
putin bringt damit leid und zerstörung
über seine direkten nachbarn
er verletzt die souveränität und die
grenzen der ukraine
er gefährdet das leben von unzähligen
unschuldigen in der ukraine dem bruder
volk russlands
plötzlich stellt er damit auch die
friedensordnung unseres kontinents in
fragen für all das gibt es keine
rechtfertigung das ist putins krieg
klare und besorgte worte von
bundeskanzler scholz heute mittag eben
in einer reaktion auf den einmarsch
herzlich willkommen hier aus berlin ich
darf meine gäste vorstellen marieluise
beck ist bei uns ehemalige grünen
politikerin auch schon damals mit dem
schwerpunkt osteuropa leitet mit ihrem
mann ralf fücks das zentrum liberale
moderne und hat seit vielen jahren
engste beziehungen zur ukraine
ich begrüße markus kaim leiter der
forschungsgruppe sicherheitspolitik der
stiftung wissenschaft und politik
zugeschaltet ist als elmar brok von der
cdu langjähriger vorsitzender des
auswärtigen ausschusses des europäischen
parlaments schönen guten abend herr brok
und herzlich willkommen johannes warwick
professor für internationale beziehungen
und europäische politik an der
universität halle-wittenberg
projektes ist ein tag der hätten
frau beck herr harbeck ihr parteifreund
hat gesagt heute das ist ein tag der
hätte nie passieren dürfen was ist ihre
reaktion auf diesen tag
lebe und arbeite ja mit sehr viel
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer und russen
und großen georgien und bei uns in die
tränen geflossen im büro aber ich war
nicht überrascht von dieser nachricht
und ich würde sagen wer so seit wochen
die choreografie gesehen hat die
militärische choreografie der
systematischen aufmarsch und die
umzingelung der ukraine vom norden vom
osten und über das schwarze meer im
süden
wer da überrascht ist das kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen denn putin der so etwas
aufgebaut hat kann ja nicht einfach
sagen
es waren haben wir allemal besuch mit
mir gesprochen und es eigentlich sind
sie doch ganz vernünftige leute und ich
ziehe meine leute wieder ab es musste
etwas passieren und es ist das passiert
das jetzt da ist und es ist eine
katastrophe das ist eine menschliche
katastrophe es wird schon gestorben und
wir wissen nicht ob nicht europa noch
weiter betroffen wird es nur die ukraine
herr brok sie haben jahrelang im
europäischen parlament waren sie als
abgeordneter lange jahre vorsitzende des
auswärtigen ausschusses an so einem tag
was war da heute ihre reaktionen
wie viel traurigkeit
allerdings und da muss ich frau weg
geben kann überraschen wer das essay von
mutigen vom letzten sommer gelesen hat
dann muss der stunde steht alles dann
die rede vom ogh mit einer kurzfassung
dieses es
nämlich keine staatlichkeit der ukraine
aussuchen und möglich die
lügengeschichten dass die nadel gefährde
das der genozid ist das ist alles alibi
bevölkerung darstellt ja alles nicht und
wir müssen aber sehen dass putin der
völlig gescheitert ist sein ganzen
modernisieren völlig gescheitert ist
allein von rohstoffexporten abhängig
sind die bald auch nicht mehr denken
können benötigt werden je mehr wir
erfolgreich im kampf gegen den
klimawandel sind haben braucht man will
hier gas öl
dieser putin denkt in den kategorien
dass ärzte und kann zum zarenreich
selbst die sowjetunion erreicht in
dieser rede
lenin und stalin kritisiert dass sie
teil republik eingerichtet haben so
beispielsweise ukraine aber nicht nur
dort
nationalismus zu wecken die identität
einer ukrainische zögern dies werden die
so nicht gegeben aber weil das teil
alles russlands ist da konnte man
deutlich lesen das ist hier nicht um
dann was oder irgendwer kurz geht
sondern dass es hier darum geht dass ein
berichten
was war ihr empfinden heute morgen als
ich die nachrichten haben also ich
wusste natürlich nicht dass heute
passieren würde aber ich glaube ich kann
mich dem nur anschließen das ist jetzt
unoriginell aber wenn man militärisches
handeln herunterbricht was bedeutet dass
es bedeutet den willen militärische
maßnahmen zu ergreifen und die fähigkeit
dazu und die entwicklung der fähigkeit
dazu die haben wir genau über den
letzten wochen gesehen die 120 bis 150
tausend mann rund um die ukraine und
alle geheimdienstberichte die auch aus
den usa zu uns gekommen sind haben wir
aber eine sehr vorsichtig die
argumentiert die fähigkeit ist da ob der
politische wille dafür da ist das wissen
wir noch nicht so genau und spätestens
mit montagabend war es klar und
mittlerweile wird nach dem was wir
wissen muss man ja sagen sind die
letzten wochen diplomatisch lügen
verbreitet worden und zwar eine
militärkampagne plan sicher nicht in
einem tag so dass sich der wirklich
unguter eindruck aufdrängt dass die
entscheidung für das vorgehen was wir
heute gesehen haben ich will sagen
spätestens im herbst letzten jahres
gefallen hat und dann ist aber die frage
warum hat der westen dann nicht anders
reagiert genau aber bevor wir darüber
sprechen ich würde gerne noch mit in die
diskussion mehr was war ihre reaktion
also auch dieses gefühl sie haben ja
einen appell unterzeichnet wo sie dafür
geworben haben dass man halte er für
eine deeskalation geworben haben jetzt
heute ist man nun war es die absolute
eskalation was war ihre gedanken dauer
nun zunächst ich beneide meine drei vor
rednerinnen dass sie alles schon genau
gewusst haben ich habe es nicht gewusst
ich bin insofern überrascht und die
brutalität und die kaltschnäuzigkeit
beginnt das wird durchgezogen wird bin
ich überrascht ich wunder nicht die
ziele uns das ist vollkommen klar dass
diese ziele bestanden haben nämlich in
der mir gewissermaßen einen
sicherheitsgürtel zu schaffen und auch
die souveränität nicht wirklich
anzuerkennen das war klar dass aber
jetzt ein großer krieg dafür in der
politischen einschätzung nötig ist das
hat mich schon überrascht ich hätte eher
mit kleineren aktionen mit die
stabilisierung auf andere art gerechnet
und ich habe auch erwartet dass der
westen ernsthafter etwas ernsthafter auf
russische sicherheitsinteressen eingeht
und versucht über diese frage zu
verhandeln das ist nicht passiert
insofern liegt der schwarze peter
eindeutig in moskau gar keine frage aber
es gibt auch versäumnisse auf unserer
seite das sollten wir auch klar benennen
ok sehr gerne
zitieren das heute morgen der
generalinspekteur der bundeswehr
etwas ganz ungewöhnliches gemacht hat
nämlich einen tweet abgesetzt und er
sagt wir haben es alle kommen sehen und
wir waren nicht in der lage mit unseren
argumenten
durchzudringen die folgerungen aus der
krim an sektion zu ziehen und umzusetzen
das fühlt sich nicht gut an ich bin
angefressen das heißt da ist jemand der
sagt vor acht jahren mit der krim aktion
haben wir gesehen der bruch des
völkerrechts zwingt uns dazu neben dem
dialog auch zu sagen wir sind stark
genug um nicht weitere solche
überschreitungen und militärischen
entente hinzunehmen und das wollte bei
uns niemand habe es hat ja noch einen
versuch gegeben ist diplomatisch zu
regeln stolz war der mann war daher kein
waren waren alle zu naiv haben sie sich
alle vorführen darf nicht an guten nein
ich würde da nicht den stab brechen
wollen also ich kann nichts schlechtes
daran finden dass der bundeskanzler
versucht halt was er versucht hat dass
die bundesministerin sich bemüht hat
dass der amerikanische präsident sich
bemüht hat der französische präsident in
den letzten wochen in einer intensität
die schon beschämend war beklemmend weil
man den pro-russischen präsidenten eine
position gebracht hat eine zentrale
position die man eigentlich nicht zu
kommen alle einzeln zu ihm gegangen das
fand ich manchmal auch grants sodass wir
haben dass man sich da bemüht hat das
kann ich ihnen nicht übel nehmen oder zu
verwerfen und letztlich bleibe ich bei
den punkt die entscheidung längst
gefallen und sie haben nicht durchschaut
vielleicht auch nicht durchschauen
können
dass die würfel längst gefallen waren
und das eigentlich von anfang an keine
chance bestanden
und wie gefährlich ist es denn jetzt
herr bruch wie gefährlich ist es ist das
was was putin dort jetzt macht moment
jetzt höre ich gerade wir einen moment
der burg ihr parteikollege friedrich
merz hat äußert sich jetzt gerade zu den
ereignissen gehen wir da mal kurz live
drauf
der lage in der ukraine
befasst und mit der dramatischen
zuspitzung die wir seit der letzten
nacht dort erleben wir sind uns in der
bundestagsfraktion einig dieser
vierundzwanzigster februar 2022 ist ein
wendepunkt in unserer geschichte nicht
nur in der europäischen geschichte
sondern in der geschichte schlechthin
wir teilen die einschätzung der
bundesregierung dass es sich hier um
eine schwere die schwerst denkbare
verletzung des völkerrechtes handelt wir
teilen die einschätzung der
bundesregierung dass dies ein
angriffskrieg ist der ausschließlich von
russland ausgeht und für den
ausschließlich russland und wladimir
putin die verantwortung trägt wir weisen
darauf hin dass
wir hier eine verantwortung haben die
auch als cdu csu bundestagsfraktion aus
der opposition heraus besteht wir werden
deswegen die bundesregierung bei ihren
bemühungen diesen konflikte einzudämmen
auch in ihren allen diplomatischen
bemühungen nach kräften unterstützen wir
halten das was die bundesregierung bis
jetzt dazu gesagt hat und was der
bundeskanzler auch mit seinem kabinett
tut für richtig wir werden alle
maßnahmen unterstützen die die
bundesregierung
vornimmt um nicht nur in deutschland
sondern auch mit den europäischen
partnern innerhalb der europäischen
union mit den nato partnern innerhalb
der nato auch international unternimmt
um die auswirkungen dieses krieges zu
begrenzen wir wollen am sonntag eine
sondersitzung des deutschen bundestages
durchführen der bundeskanzler hat uns
mitgeteilt dass er eine
regierungserklärung abgeben wird wir
werden darauf hin eine
zweieinhalbstündige bundestagsdebatte
haben in der wir auch aus unserer sicht
noch einmal auf die bewertung der lage
eingehen
dieser angriffskrieg von putin und der
russischen föderation ist auf das
schwerste zu verurteilen wir wissen
trotzdem dass wir im augenblick dagegen
relativ wenig unternehmen können außer
zu appellieren ihn unverändert
unverzüglich einzustellen wir sind mit
der bundesregierung der auffassung dass
waffenlieferungen zum jetzigen zeitpunkt
nicht das richtige mittel sind darüber
hätte man allenfalls früher nachdenken
können und vielleicht müssen aber
sicherlich nicht mehr zum jetzigen
zeitpunkt wir wollen und müssen uns
darauf einrichten dass es größere
flüchtlingsbewegungen aus der ukraine
richtung westen gibt wir sind dankbar
für die bereitschaft aller
organisationen vom deutschen roten kreuz
bis hin zu vielen anderen organisationen
in deutschland die sich jetzt schon
bereit erklärt haben auch flüchtlinge
aufzunehmen und zu betreuen auch hier
hat die bundesregierung uns zugesichert
auch in den verschiedenen
ausschusssitzungen die es gestern und
heute im verlaufe des tages gegeben hat
dass sie alles tun wird um dies auch im
europäischen kontext abzustimmen und
auch mit den ländern in deutschland so
vorzubereiten dass wir hier auch einer
möglichen größeren zahl von flüchtlingen
gerecht werden können und sie auch in
deutschland unterbringen können ja das
ist die lage gerne gleich zu fragen aber
zunächst alexander dobrindt
vielen dank so weit also friedrich merz
cdu vorsitzende und dann komme ich mal
direkt zu einem bruch wie der bruch wenn
sie das eben hören was herr merz sagt
dass man eigentlich jetzt nur wenig
unternehmen kann dagegen dass man es
noch abhängig ihren kann teilen sie das
es ist ja eigentlich ein schreckliches
armutszeugnis dass wir quasi hilflos
sind
ich weiß nicht ob es ein armutszeugnis
ist aber es ist eine situation in der
wir uns befinden
denn die amerikaner die nato wir alle
wären nicht in den krieg gegen die
atommacht
und deswegen ist sie sieht das so es ist
die fehler liegen feuer nicht jetzt ich
fand es auch richtig dass verhandelt
wurde noch bis zum letzten augenblick
aber wir haben dann einen punkt
vergessen das wurde immer der satz
gesagt sondern der bewerber kommen
anderen solange man redet wird nicht
geschossen
aber man kann nur erfolgreich reden und
schießen zufrieden wenn man stärker hat
und diese stärke haben wir nicht gehabt
man muss stark sein glaubwürdig stark
seien militärisch stark sein um krieg zu
verhindern um einen faktor zu sein
dieses haben wir leider gottes über all
die jahre in der letzten fünfzehn
zwanzig jahren versorgt was wäre denn
eine stärke gewesen und wäre es richtig
gewesen friedrich merz hat eben gesagt
er ist der meinung so wie die
bundesregierung auch dass man keine
waffen liefern soll an die ukraine wie
kann könnte man denn jetzt stärker
zeigen also wir haben ja in deutschland
einen breiten konsens dass es keine
waffenlieferungen geben sollte jetzt ist
es in der tat so spät dass man nicht
mehr mehr wüsste wie man die waffen in
das land hineinbringen sollte denn es
ist davon auszugehen dass heute nach
kiew eingenommen wird damit rechnen alle
unsere freunde in der ukraine es wird
auch aus der luft angegriffen
aber wie wir die entscheidung zu sagen
dann zeigen wir dass der preis für putin
sehr sehr hoch ist und dazu nutzen wir
jedes instrumentarium das wir haben ist
das mindeste und es ist heute
entschieden worden dass von deutscher
seite blockiert worden dass das swift
system dass russland empfindlich treffen
würde wenn er aus diesem system
ausgeschlossen
oder dass deutschland gegen den
ausschluss russlands vom tüv system sich
verhält das ist dann niemanden mehr
erklärbar und dann werden unsere
solidaritätsbekundungen in der ukraine
nur noch mit großer bitterkeit gesehen
und ich finde das sollten wir uns
klarmachen der gipfel beginnt ja erst
heute abend vielleicht gibt uns auch
darüber wird dann 80 aber bereits dazu
öffentlich verhalten und das ist für die
ukraine eine fast unerträgliche
botschaft wir sollten uns das klar
machen wer kein wäre es sinnvoll und er
hätten sie es für besser gehalten hätte
man etwas verhindern können wenn wir
waffen geliefert hätten die ukraine ja
ich glaube schon ich halte das für ein
kapitalen fehler der deutschen
sicherheitspolitik das kategorisch
ausgeschlossen zu haben das argument
dass wir in krisengebiete keine waffen
liefern stimmt ja von vorne bis hinten
nicht und die zweit das zweite argument
das zentrale deutsche argument hat sich
als pferdefuß erwiesen dass das dann
etwa lautete so lange wir verhandeln
solange wir vor allen dingen im
normandie tomatis deutschland besonders
exponiert verhandeln können wir uns
nicht leisten eine position zu beziehen
dabei haben wir immer unparteiischer
getan als wir wirklich gewesen sind ich
meine die deutsche position nicht im
militärischen sinne aber im normativen
sinne war doch eher die ukraine in ihrem
kampf zu unterstützen nicht dass russen
putins russland zu unterstützen und ich
bin da ganz bayern brook letztlich muss
man stärke zeigen und das wäre ein
moment gewesen ich bilde mir nicht ein
um nicht missverstanden zu werden dass
das die militärische balance verändert
hätte aber der entscheidende punkt ist
die kosten hoch zu treiben und da sind
wir nicht sich bei einer ganz zynischen
abwägung die kosten in menschenleben für
eine russische invasion
in die höhe zu treiben also letztlich
die verluste in der russischen soldaten
zu helfen
herwig sie haben ja sehr versucht das
dass das ist eine annäherung ist sie
sagen man muss auch die russischen
sicherheitsinteressen mit bedenken ich
wie stehen sie denn dazu zu diesem
ausgleich da der stärke und hätte man
waffen liefern sollen an die ukraine
ich finde diese diskussion von allen
dreien geht in eine völlig falsche
richtung erstmals ein bruch es ist keine
frage von nicht vorhandener stärke wir
sind stark und die nato ist in der lage
abschreckungsfähigkeit sicherzustellen
wir geben im übrigen sehr viel mehr geld
aus für militär als russland also wir
sind staat das ist keine frage von
stärker weil wir waren und sind und aus
guten gründen nicht bereit für die
ukraine in den krieg zu ziehen das muss
man mal so deutlich sagen und deswegen
bleiben nur wirtschaftssanktionen
politische maßnahmen und die
bereitschaft über diese fragen zu
verhandeln das ist die prämisse insofern
wir sind nicht schwach sondern wir
wollen einfach nicht für die ukraine in
den krieg ziehen das ist der punkt das
kann man bitter finden oder falschen
aber ich persönlich finde es vernünftig
weil wir uns nicht in eine potenzielle
nukleare eskalation wer brooks gesagt
hat
ist auch die konsequenz dass wir die
ukraine aufgeben darf ich ein farbiger
noch kurz ich habe ja in
der farbe darf ich ganz kurz zu ihnen
was sagen ich erlebe das ja zum zweiten
mal einen krieg in europa es ist nicht
der erste krieg in europa wir haben den
krieg bei dem zerfallenden jugoslawien
gegen bosnien gehabt und die bosse haben
immer zu uns gesagt ihr müsst uns nicht
eure söhne schicken wir können und
werden und selbst verteidigen aber gibt
uns dazu die möglichkeit und wir hatten
ein waffenembargo verhängt und wir haben
den bosnien das völkerrecht abgesprochen
sich selbst zu verteidigen die ukraine
haben nie gefordert dass wir sie
verteidigen sollten sondern sie haben
gesagt gibt uns die möglichkeit uns zur
wehr zu setzen und das zu verweigern
das argument gegen waffenlieferungen ist
ja kein hat angedeutet die
waffenlieferungen würden das russische
risiko kalküle keinen millimeter
verändern und wenn man fordert dass das
dann noch blutiger wird dann ist das
eine zynische haltung entweder bewähren
mit wirksamen maßnahmen gegen russland
in den krieg zu ziehen oder nicht und
wir sind es nicht und das aus gründen
und aus diesem dilemma werden was
lieferung auch nicht raus zoubek noch
ein satz der vergleich zu den
balkankriegen hinter an allen ecken und
enden wir hatten den balkankriegen nicht
mit einer potenziellen nuklearen
eskalation zu sehen wir sehen doch jetzt
das russland zu allem entschlossen ist
und wir sehen auch dass das ziel klar
ist und wenn wir uns in dieser frage mit
russland an belegen wollen dann kann ich
nur sagen viel spaß das wäre
unverantwortlich da würde ich ihr war
das jetzt gerade sagen zu der möglichen
eskalation und zu dem was russland zudem
dass russland bereit ist können wir mal
kurz rein was war die mir putin in diese
richtung in richtung europa gesagt hat
alle müssen wissen dass
wir sofort reagieren und es werden
solche folgen entstehen die sie in ihrer
geschichte noch nie erlebt haben wir
sind bereit zu jeder entwicklung vor der
wir uns wiederfinden werden die
entscheidung ist gefallen und ich hoffe
meine worte werden gehört
die baltischen staaten wenn sie recht
haben wissen dass sie nicht verteidigt
werden wenn der korridor geschlossen
wird zwischen belarus und kaliningrad
das bedeutet dass polen damit rechnen
muss dass wir nicht an ihrer seite
stehen werden das ist eine botschaft die
so tief in die uns als westliches
bündnis und gemeinschaft hineingeht und
ich finde das ist eine botschaft ist die
putin möchte dass er belehrt die nato
ist ein papiertiger herr brok und dann
erkennen ja wie der bruch
also wir müssen doch sehen dass putin
nicht nur die der ukraine die
staatlichkeit abgesprochen hat und mit
manchen können wie zum vorschlag des
zum vorwurf des genozids hier den krieg
begonnen hat um sein touristisches
kohlen jahr wieder zu errichten sondern
er hat auch in seiner rede am montag zum
ausdruck gebracht wie ja auch unseren
forderungen vorher gesagt hat dass er
eine gebiet auch versandes
sicherheitsgarantie die
und zwar in den regionen die spritzen
wasser
das sind heute nato-länder das ist doch
der entscheidende punkt
das ist rumänien das sind die baltische
staaten insbesondere dann bedeutet
dieses doch das so durchmarschieren kann
wenn wir nicht stärker hin und glaubt
würde ja in den baltischen staaten
präsent sind dann kann er das mit der
feuerwehr delegieren wenn man sich das
mal geografisch stammen von der
bevölkerungszahl anschaut und hier wird
deutlich machen dass es hier grenzen
gibt aber
[Musik]
trocken wie das geplant ist ich hoffe
dass die republik deutschland sorgt auf
diese weise entsprechend mitmacht wir
haben uns nach 1990 an die regeln
gehalten
es hat keine festen arge installation
und puppen östlich der elbe gegeben
trotz der weit in die europäische union
das ist ein bisschen geändert worden
nachdem
2014 durch dass er politik und diese
geschichten
nach dem überfall auf die ukraine und
jetzt kann gut die nicht nur fordern
dass das auch nicht gemacht wenn wir
darauf eingehen das heißt polen wieder
zum blasii russlands gehört wie er das
fordert das ist steht er an der oder
dann sind wir wieder in einer situation
dass wir machtpolitisch nachbarland
sonst nicht unser ziel die frage nach
abstrichen auch
nicht funktioniert
wie gefährlich ist dass russland als
eine nuklearmacht die sich jetzt erst
mal wo man das den eindruck hat sie
lässt sich nicht abschrecken das war
doch eine klare drohung die putin der
ausspricht wie gefährlich ist es für die
nato für die nato staaten polen für die
baltischen staaten für uns in europa
also ich glaube wir tun gerade dann
nicht alles für bare münze zu nehmen was
aus moskau kommt an botschaften
die reden der letzten tage und des
russischen präsidenten ein ja zum teil
gespenstische bizarre züge das kann man
das nicht sagen und ich glaube wir tun
gut daran er zu fragen was können wir
tun und nicht immer darauf zu reagieren
und da sind die ersten schritte der nato
eingeleitet worden aber ganz am anfang
haben sie alle gesagt wir hätten wenn
wir wenn man die reden gut sich angehört
hätte von fusion hätte man wissen können
dass er das das durchzieht also warum
sollen wir ihnen jetzt nicht ernst
nehmen weil es tatsächlich glaube ich
jetzt züge annimmt dass also ich fühlte
mich bei der rede am montagabend an den
führerbunker in berlin 19 45 erinnert
das war eine totale abkopplung von der
realität von genozid zu reden wenn diese
abkopplung von der realität dazu führt
dass er eben ein marschiert dann ist es
doch total dramatisch und gerade
besonders gefährlich und
besorgniserregend wenn man ja kaum noch
mal ich hoffe dass ich in allem unrecht
habe ich hoffe dass ich in allem unrecht
habe aber ich schließe nicht aus dass
putin inzwischen in einer solchen
isolation auch psychischen isolation
lebt dass für ihn das lebensziel die
wiederherstellung des russischen
imperiums das hat ist eben gesagt worden
aber auch der belegt ist dass der westen
nicht in der lage ist russland stand zu
halten und das kann er austesten auf dem
westbalkan das tut er im augenblick
methodik und das kann er austesten wenn
es um die verteidigung der bayerischen
staaten geht und es tut mir leid aber
die generäle sagen das baltikum ist
durch die nato so wie sie im augenblick
aussieht nicht verteidigt
weil dazu wenig truppen sind zuerst die
theater wenig drucken da und ist in den
google aufwischen gegebenheiten den
dramatisch wir haben soldaten dort
reingeschickt das zeigt wir sind bereit
gewesen
geiseln zu geben und damit eine
abschreckung zu versuchen aber wenn sie
vom führerbunker sprechen ich habe es
nicht gesagt aber wenn sie von diesem
wahn sprechen dann kann niemand
ausschließen dass diese provokation und
dieser versuch ist auszuprobieren
unternommen wird und dann ist der krieg
noch näher bei uns als jetzt herwig wie
gefährlich halten sie diese drohungen
die wir das gehört haben von putin und
auch die tatsache dass wir es halt eben
auch mit einer atommacht zu tun haben
wie gefährlich kann das werden für ganz
europa
das ist sehr gefährlich das
eskalationspotenzial dieser krise ist
enorm aber ich finde wir sollten die
debatte auch ein bisschen vom kopf auf
die füße stellen es macht einen
unterschied
und sicherlich auch in der
risikokalkulation putins ob es um ein
nato-mitglied oder meinen nicht geht und
insofern ist es ein anderer schall die
ukraine ist ein sonderfall ich spielte
auch in der russischen außenpolitischen
vorstellung eine andere rolle als das
baltikum oder polen das heißt ich
erwarte überhaupt nicht dass jetzt das
nato territorium angegriffen wird und im
übrigen haben wir einen nuklear schirm
garantiert durch die amerikaner der dann
gewissermaßen wirklich den großen krieg
auslösen würde und ich sehe überhaupt
nicht warum putin das riskieren sollte
seine ziele sind berechenbar die sind
sehr sehr schädlich und wirklich
unanständig und mit fürchterlichen
mitteln werden die jetzt umgesetzt wird
das ziel denke ich ist nicht das nato
territorium
herauszufordern sondern die ukraine als
sicherheitsgurte um russland zu legen
und dadurch die ukraine dauerhaft in
stabil zu halten und damit zu verhindern
dass die ukraine ins westliche lager
camp das ist okay das ist schlimm genug
aber wir sollten jetzt panik machen und
den unterschied machen nato mitglied
oder nicht nato mitglieder
wir hatten aber die abtrennung in
georgien also es ist nicht nur die
ukraine wir hatten die abtrennung von
moldawien transnistrien
es ist nicht das erste mal dass diese
aggressive form für länder die ja nur
sich dem westen an nähern wollten es
ging um keine nato gegner gingen nicht
mal um den überall diesen wollte ja
diese denn sogar wird liegen lassen
lasst uns gemeinsam an danach schauen
was wir denn jetzt tun können weil viele
menschen machen sich wirklich große
sorgen heute abend treffen sich in
brüssel die eu regierungschefs druck was
was kann man jetzt tun wie schafft also
und wie einig wird der wird die eu da
bleiben bis jetzt sind sie ja ziemlich
geschlossen also wo sagen sie was wäre
ein guter ansatz vorhanden wo das denn
dass wir den eindruck haben dass könnte
noch eine möglichkeit geben putin zu
stoppen
ich glaube nicht das ist eine
möglichkeit gibt putin zustande wenn man
seine zielsetzung sich vor augen hält
was er jetzt durch führt dass sie nicht
bodentruppen losmarschiert aber auch
kiew zu
dieser frage die da kommt die frage ist
nur hinter die west ukraine mit oder
nicht auch da gibt's dann differenzieren
zu seiner rede vom montag er sagte dass
die westlichen gebiete die den hitler
stalin zum training gekommen ist wird
von ihnen anders betrachtet als die
übrige ukraine auch hochinteressant sagt
auch deutsche verantwortung diesen
bereich geschichtlich und ich glaube
dass wir deutlich machen dass ein erstes
die strafe muss hofer ist jetzt nicht
mehr preis sondern die strafe weil er
diese aggression gemacht hat das muss
hart sein diese dinge kosten uns auch
etwas
energiepreise und manches andere mehr da
kann man nicht business as usual machen
dann macht er sich tot und sagt das geht
alles so weiter ich habe mich nicht an
45 jährige ich habe mich an 38 jahre alt
wiesmann tschechoslowakei oder
vielleicht den beginn des grimmelt lese
vor
putin hat durch diesen schritt
diplomatie und politik verlassen gewalt
angewandt
[Musik]
aber in wirklichkeit ist dieses ein
durch gewalt ein verzicht auf diplomatie
politik
und deswegen müssen die so sollen und
deswegen muss die sicherheit ist
naturgemäß stark sein und deswegen
müssen wir sowohl bei den sanktionen
fordern gehen dass es besser für ihn
wird und zweitens müssen wir deutlich
machen dass wir das nato territorium
absichern damit er keine falsche
mitteilung bekommen das problem bei
diktaturen toren ist nämlich oftmals
dass sie fehleinschätzungen haben weil
sie nicht mit der härte der antwort der
demokratie und rechnen können hier
müsste ich möchte ich mal waren während
die beratende tätigkeit und schröder
gemacht angewiesen ist da
hat er gesagt diese wählen wer wochen
und diese leute nichts zu hören
ist
wie schafft muss die sanktionen jetzt
die sanktionen seien wenn die eu
regierungschefs zusammen sitzen also wo
gibt es eine möglichkeit zu sagen das
tut dann weder das ist so eine starke
strafe dass man wenn sie so stark
während die fragen haben jetzt schon
längst gemacht also als politikberater
sollte ich das nicht sagen aber ich bin
in dieser frage ein bisschen ratlos
vielleicht davon dass auch mal sagen
weil sozusagen über die letzten wochen
war doch eine kernbotschaft aller
westlichen hauptstädte das preisschild
zu zeigen in verschiedenen
begrifflichkeiten es wird gewaltige
sanktion geben riesige sanktion sodass
letztlich präsident putin dorf sich
selber in den letzten wochen kosten
nutzen kalkulation anstellen konnte was
will er erreichen was droht ihm und ihm
eine ist nicht naiv also nord stream
zwei dass das zur disposition gestellt
wurde konnte ihm dämon das 12 thema sein
würde konnte
wenn man das jetzt schon vorher gewann
man jetzt vorhergesagt hätte schriften
aus dem zwei einfach schon vor einigen
wochen wäre das nicht sinnvoller und vor
allen dingen der öl kauft wir müssen uns
klarmachen dass das dass russland und
der staatshaushalt im wesentlichen und
sehr viel mehr vom verkauf des bus als
vom verkauf des gases lebt also wir
haben tatsächlich in den vergangenen
jahren die aufrüstung der russischen
armee bezahlt insofern hat andere
energiepolitik tatsächlich auch sinn in
dieser frage wie hoch für den kreisel
umfrage noch einmal swift muss heute
entschieden dass die ukraine wirkung
entfalten für die situation in der
ukraine dass das mittel und langfristig
wirkt wie die ja nicht bestreite aber
kann aber jetzt zumindest jetzt der
ukraine zeigen dass wir wirklich bereit
sind alles zu tun was in unserer macht
steht und wenn wir selbst davor
zurückschrecken weil wir an uns selbst
an unseren eigenen egoistischen
interessen festhalten dann wird die
ukraine sich noch mehr allein gelassen
fühlen weil er ist so schon ist er weg
was würden sie sagen was wäre jetzt ein
guter schritt auch um der ukraine zu
zeigen als europa wir stehen an ihrer
seite
ich teile die möchte eine einschätzung
von markus kaim dass wir eigentlich im
prinzip im moment keine instrumente mehr
haben und ja es wird sanktionen geben
weil das russische verhalten kann nicht
ohne konsequenzen bleiben und ich rechne
auch damit dass es eigentlich die
schwestern wirtschaftssanktionen in der
jüngeren wirtschaftsgeschichte sein
werden das heißt das hat schon einen
preis für putin er ist aber bereit
diesen preis zu zahlen und im übrigen
müssen wir
die frage wer den preis dann
letztendlich bezahlen
aber wir sollten auch mal einen schritt
weiter denken das ist glaube ich jetzt
die aufgabe von außenpolitik auch an das
morgen und das übermorgen zu denken was
wird passieren wenn russland hart
getroffen wird von den von den
sanktionen russland wird ärmer die
innenpolitik wird sich weiter
radikalisieren die dinge werden nicht
besser werden das heißt wir müssen auch
jetzt so schwer dass heute ist und so
utopisch erscheinen mag diplomatische
initiativen
vorbereiten die ein kluges management
der instabilität in europa versuchen
anzugehen das ist jetzt die aufgabe der
außenpolitik und keine panikmache keine
scharfmacherei das hilft überhaupt nicht
weil aber im moment geht es ja für die
menschen in der ukraine geht es um ihr
heute es geht nicht für die menschen in
der ukraine geht es nicht um das morgen
in russland sondern um das überleben
heute also das wäre jetzt noch mal meine
frage auch als wäre kein einflug das
muss man einfach mal so nüchtern sagen
wir haben keinen einfluss und wir haben
keinen willen das zu machen weil wir
nicht für die ukraine in den krieg zu
ziehen werden und das ist auch
vernünftig einbruch wie sehen sie es
gibt es gibt es etwas wo man den rhein
wo man die ukraine wo man den menschen
jetzt helfen kann
nein man kann humanitäre leistungen
vorsehen es werden zu euch die
überlegung angestellt was macht man mit
flüchtlingen das ist ein grausamer
mitteilung der stimmig mit einem kleinen
verein ist ein bestimmtes maß an
hilflosigkeit jetzt vorhanden aber wir
müssen auch sehen dass putin sich nicht
ermutigt fühlt dass er weiter gehen kann
weil er diese schwache westen völlig
nicht in der lage ist und wenn wir jetzt
schon überlegen
wir machen übermorgen alles wieder wie
früher mit russland dann ist das der weg
der denn auch andere europäische staaten
gefährdet und wir deutschen müssen
endlich begreifen was unsere
geschichtliche verantwortung ist wir
haben die baltischen staaten polen zieht
man verraten dass sie rufe hat hineinkam
und deswegen will ich
dieses klar machen ist schon eine
sauerei gegenüber der ukraine wieso
gesagt er hätte aus historischen gründen
dürfen nicht sagt gegen russland sein
die unter deutschland am meisten
gelitten rahmen ihrer nazi zeit das muss
vor augen gehalten werden das weiß doch
niemanden deutschland und deswegen
müssen wir jetzt
vorweg wir müssen politisch etwas
anerkennen was unbeliebtes in
deutschland dass putin russland derzeit
ein gegner ist zu uns und nicht unserer
partner wir haben versucht
modernisierungs partnerschaft anzubieten
wir haben versucht so viele formate des
dialogs zu führen bin der immer mit
dabei denn es gibt ja so viele russen
die selber eigentlich auch ein besseres
leben wollten das leben ist schlechter
geworden unter putin weil die ökonomie
eigentlich am boden liegt wir müssen
sehen jetzt geht er als gegner gegen die
ganze freie welt vor gegen europa er
stößt alle regeln um und die menschen
die jetzt das erleiden müssen die
ukraine die müssen wenigsten ist bei uns
offene türen finden wenn sie jetzt
versuchen zu fliehen und ich weiß dass
unsere familien die sind jetzt auf der
straße die sind bei dem versuch in polen
über die grenze zu kommen wir müssen
wirklich aber meine sorge gab ist ja
jetzt auch von der bundesregierung dass
man die milliarden auftrag menschen auf
ganz ganz wichtig
wo kann man denn also wenn man daran
nicht mehr ansetzen kann wenn man das
wenn man sieht wir sind hier
letztendlich kommen wir da nicht weiter
was heißt das denn dann also wie das was
heißt das für die ukraine wir geben die
auf also wie gehen wir damit um ich
glaube die bedrückende perspektive und
ich räume frei möglich einen die
bedrückt mich heute wirklich ist die
ganz große das heißt das für die
gemeinsame europäische sicherheitsnorm
weil es liegt ja eine traurige
schlussfolgerung nahe dass wir das ende
der gemeinsamen europäischen sicherheits
ordnung gerade sehen das wird eine
westliche europäische sicherheits
ordnung geben aber das geteilte immer
brokers group angesprochen charta von
paris mit allen prinzipien
unverletzlichkeit des territoriums
territorialen integrität nicht
anwendungen der gewalt das gilt
jenseits des nato gebietes
offensichtlich nicht mehr zumindest
unterwegs
jetzt muss energie oder seien jetzt mal
zehn jahre weiter denkt oder die frage
mir stelle die wollen wir gemeinsame
europäische sicherheit gewährleisten
dann sehe ich im moment fürchte nicht
wenig anknüpfungspunkte und das ist
eigentlich der ganze teil
das ist die frage die stärken der
demokratie deshalb die letzte frage
jetzt für sie hier
die stärkung der demokratie auch in
russland
ist das ist dieser krieg vielleicht auch
eine chance dass ich etwas gegen putin
auflehnt in seinem land das traue ich
mir kein urteil zu das geht an frau beck
weil die kann die innenpolitische
situation besser beurteilen als ich das
kann ich bin sicher und ich versuche
auch in meinen ausführungen immer zu
differenzieren zwischen der aktuellen
regierung und nicht immer russland zu
sagen weil ich glaube wir alle dass
viele teile der russischen bevölkerung
vielleicht ganz anders denken und da
sollten wir uns immer vergegenwärtigen
sie sind jetzt schon mal entlassen war
ich weiß dass man so an so einem tag
gibt es viele anfragen wer aber wir
sprechen hier einfach nochmal jetzt
weiter es geht genau um diese frage der
demokratie ist dass ein punkt wo man
auch die bevölkerung in russland stärken
kann wir sehen seit jahren dass die
repression nach innen mit der aggression
nach außen im gleichschritt geht und die
menschen die den geraden rücken gemacht
haben und es gibt wunderbare aufrechte
menschen memorial hat sich gegen die
krim addition ausgesprochen gegen den
krieg im don was sie alle sind
inzwischen verschwunden es gibt für die
menschen in russland fast keine
möglichkeit mehr
informationen zu bekommen die jenseits
der staatlichen propaganda sind und wenn
die staatliche propaganda in alle
wohnstuben reinspielt die russen werden
jetzt genital verfolgt und es gibt
massengräber wie sollen sie sich eine
eigene meinung bilden und wir werden
nicht mehr hereingelassen
warwick was würden sie denn sagen ist
das ist das ein punkt wo sie sagen da
müssten wir auch ansetzen um demokratie
in russland zu stützen damit wir
sonst auf partnerschaftliche höhe mit
dem russischen volk sein können
wir sollten unsere kontakte in die
zivilgesellschaft universitäts
partnerschaften und anderes mehr
natürlich intensivieren aber die
rahmenbedingungen dafür sind denkbar
schlecht im moment und wir müssen ein
stück weit akzeptieren dass unser
einfluss darauf begrenzt ist und regime
wechsel ist schon in anderen staaten
schiefgegangen und demokratie export
auch nicht das schaffen wir von außen
nicht das ist eine entwicklung die aus
russland selber kommen
wir haben einen westlichen block und
gewissermaßen ein ostblock und das ist
ein desaster es gibt keine europäische
sicherheits- und friedensordnung mehr
aber wir müssen darüber nachdenken wie
wir sie wieder aufbauen können herr brok
ist das eine schwierigere situation noch
als zu zeiten des kalten krieges
eigentlich
ja meine sicherheit angeht bürger habt
die konservativ war und der westen war
stark noch verteidigungsfähigkeit
verteidigung zu gelten und so ist der
frieden gesichert worden gekommen diese
situation zurück wir müssen den westen
so stark machen die demokratien so stark
machen hier stehen die westlichen
demokratien europäischen demokratien
gegen eine östliche diktatur und will
vor allem auch deswegen die ukraine
übernehmen weil er eine panische angst
von einer freien demokratischen und
wirtschaftlichen sozialen erfolgreichen
ukraine ab weil ihnen dann die leute
weglaufen in moskau hatte heute schon
keine mehrheiten werden und deswegen ist
dieser krieg auch ein instrument gegen
demokratie im eigenen land aber dennoch
ist ihre frage richtig wir müssen die
zivile helfer stützen so weit das geht
man sollte vielleicht für fernsehsender
die nach russland reingehen geht's bei
den haushaltsplanberatungen in berlin
die haushaltstitel vergrößern um in
diesen bereichen
das wirklich beunruhigend ist dass die
vereinigten staaten sehr viel wackeliger
sind und wenn man jetzt verfolgt das
tram putin
bejubelt als starken mann und wir alle
wissen dass tatsächlich sogar in den usa
die demokratie erschüttert bar ist dann
denke ich schon dass wir inzwischen in
einer dramatischen situation sind als zu
zeiten als auch eine wunderbare
ostpolitik von willy brandt
abgestützt wurde durch eine starke nato
durch eine gemeinsame nato und durch die
usa das hat zusammen ganz ganz kurz zum
schluss noch weg
wir sind am ende der sendung oder ganz
kurze jetzt am strand wenn sie auf die
ukraine schauen präsident jens g hat
heute dem österreichischen kollegen
gesagt ich weiß gar nicht wie lange ich
noch lebe und wie lange ist mein land
noch gibt so ist es wir gehen davon aus
dass die ukrainische armee innerhalb von
tagen aufgerieben sein wird und das ist
tatsächlich
eine souveräne ukraine nicht mehr geben
wird was diese regierung macht ob sie
ins exil geht eine sehr schwierige frage
das heißt nämlich die eigene haut zu
retten
während andere bleiben müssen was da
alles kommt ich weiss es nicht ist
bricht mir wirklich fast das herz vielen
dank frau beck herr brok erwarb ich an
einem wirklich denkwürdigen und auch
traurigen tag hier bei phoenix werden
sie nämlich den ganzen tag darüber
informiert über die aktuellen
entwicklungen und um 22 uhr 30 dann
sehen wir uns hier wieder und haben noch
eine phoenix runde unter anderem auch
mit klaus von dohnanyi ich freue mich
wenn sie wieder dabei sind bis dahin
tschüss
[Musik]
das war die folge